hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca I'm Borderlands three and
we have week two of the Borderlands
anniversary celebration and week two is
going to be all about rare spawn hunts
so as always like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new and let's get
started
if you're unaware for this week it is
all about the rarest one hunts so
certain characters that are rare spawns
like rack man el dragon jr. Road dog etc
those guys are considered rare spawns
you get those from bounty boards or just
happen to find them throughout the world
and those will drop specific legendaries
especially this week they have a high
chance of dropping those specific
legendaries so right now we're gonna be
going into what characters are within
the event as well as what legendaries
they come with and then I'm going to be
showing you their location right after
this so for the characters and what they
come with the first one is gonna be
recommend he's gonna be dropping the
legendary pistol Knight flyer el dragon
jr. will be having the unleash the
dragon legendary artifact Road Dogg will
be dropping the redline which is a
legendary shotgun Indo tyrant will give
you any random customization force
troopers will drop random legendary
class mods the demo Skagen gives you a
legendary shield unstoppable as the band
of story story AK I believe is the
legendary shield thunk and sloth gives
you the it space legendary grenade mod
Maxo Trillian gives you the horror
horizon which is a legendary shotgun
Boorman nate's drops the psycho stabber
a legendary pistol princess tart ella ii
gives you the hive a legendary rocket
launcher mother of Gorgons it gives you
a random legendary artifact reg ever
gives over at random legendary grenade
mod and Ernest Mikan forcer drops the
masterwork crossbow a legendary sniper
rifle for the first woman recommend he's
gonna be in carnivore he's gonna be very
very off the map obviously can't
carnivore if you've gotten to this part
in the game very huge map but you
definitely want to be taking a vehicle
to get to this place and he's gonna be
off in the very very small little corner
of the map on the bottom left that's
we're gonna find rack man one thing I do
want to preface those that in the
gameplay you will notice that some of
the people do not spawn for me that does
not mean that they are not there that
just means that they didn't spawn for me
in that game
the thing with rare spawns is that of
course they are supposed to be rare so
not every single time
you go up to them are they going to be
there 100% so if you happen to go to
that spot and they're not there just
saving quit and then come back and
hopefully they'll be there again I did
that a lot when I was trying to farm
dinklebot resolutions call and also if
you want to check specific locations I
are like I said I'm using the
borderlands 3 interactive map my map
Genie shout out to those guys that map
has basically everything you want from
ammo locations to iridium spots to boss
locations and then these boss locations
as well for the rare spawns which is how
I got this to work next up is gonna be
el dragon jr. he's gonna be located in
the Jacobs estate you honestly could
probably just farm him by going right
off from spawn where the fast travel is
but if there happens to be a checkpoint
or some respawn location even closer I
do believe there is one when the loot
tank farm existed so you could probably
drop from there drop down and shoot him
rinse and repeat I believe that is the
fastest way if you do want to get the
unleash the dragon legendary artifact
Road dog is in the splinter lands I
believe he's in the upper section
depending on which way of looking at the
map we're gonna be coming back here for
another rare spawn but he's gonna be in
the upper section towards where most of
his little guys are gonna be chillin in
this little section interesting on the
map once again he drops the red line
legendary shotgun then we're going back
to Eaton 6 to go cover the flood more
basin which is where the endo tyrunt is
and that will drop you a random
customization sadly he did not spawn in
my game I believe a badass zealot did
with a shield and armor and health which
was pretty shitty but he'll roughly
spawn around there I don't actually know
the specific location it could be in
that outhouse word that one zealot came
from it could be up here in a cave as
they're seeing on screen that I happen
to check because it was this big black
thing and I was wondering if there was
going to be anything that was coming
from there but obviously I didn't get it
to spawn this time and actually shot it
a couple times just to make sure and I
he still went in spawn so I got some
very [ __ ] luck with that but he is
around that location
next we're jumping all the way to
Promethea in the Atlas HQ to go fight
the force troopers and they're gonna be
very close to the spawn point as you'll
see on the map now I haven't actually
found a way to get up there of course
you have to go all the way to the right
and then go up the stairs to the second
level and go back so you probably have
to keep doing that if you want to farm
them but I'm fairly certain that there
is a checkpoint once you enter the main
section of Atlas HQ so if you do plan on
farming these guys for legendary class
mods I would go into the Atlas HQ first
check that spawn point and then run
outside so you go from the middle
portion then go to your right as opposed
to going from spawn all the way to the
right up the stairs and go all the way
back just to fight these guys for them
not to beat and we're going to the
beginning area of Pandora the droughts
to fight the demo Skagen probably a lot
of you guys have been farming him a lot
or been fighting him as well I mean I've
come across him just by accident
multiple times he's gonna be dropping a
legendary random shield he's gonna be in
this location here then we're gonna be
going to the amber mine to go fight the
unstoppable he's gonna be with his band
of homies and that it makes a lot of
sense since he's dropping the band of
story AK so he that's gonna be the
legendary shield and this is the
location here there's gonna be a lot of
guys here so definitely be aware he's
also one of the biggest people in that
group so even though you're gonna be in
the [ __ ] fighting a lot of guys just
look for the fat dude and if there is
none then just reload the safe we're
going to Conrad's hold to fight thunk
and sloth with to get the its piss
legendary grenade mod all you have to do
from spawn is take a right and then go
straight into the building and that will
be there I'm wondering I don't actually
know if there's a checkpoint after that
area but if there is a checkpoint after
that area let me know in the comments
because then you can either go from
spawn to this building or go from that
checkpoint and then just backtrack into
the building and you should once again
see a really big thick guy and then
you'll know that you got the right
person if not just quit and load the
save again next we're going into the
voracious canopy and we have to go
inside the crash of the family jewel
where we fight Genevieve and this is for
max a trillion to get the legendary
shotgun the horizon good luck in through
this place I still can't get through
this place it's looking about five
minutes to navigate through this but
it's such a pain because there's so many
twists and turns you can get lost
everywhere and according to the map I
actually am currently at the location
that you're seeing on screen but I don't
actually know if it's the first or the
third floor if it's the first floor it's
the it's the video you're seeing on
screen literally right as soon as you
enter you should be within that section
or if it's on the third floor then it's
at the very end I believe right before
the Jenna b-boss flight either way I
didn't get any of them to spawn in any
of those locations so I cannot confirm
this but one of you can hopefully let me
know in the comments below of course
he'll be dropping the legendary shotgun
The Horizon now for a way easier one
Bert we're gonna be going to the
Meridian outskirts on Promethea and
we're gonna be fighting Borman Nate's he
will be dropping us the psycho stabber a
legendary pistol I believe it's one of
the better melee weapon esque weapons
within the game now I do believe the
butt plug is still the best but I know
that the psycho stabber has a knife on
the end of it and I think it also shoots
knives so that can also be a thing if
you're into that stuff but if you do
want to farm him this is where he is I
mentioned we were going back to the
spawner lands and I didn't forget we're
gonna be facing this time a giant spider
and called princess tarantella ii she
drops the hive rocket launcher this was
actually the only boss out of the 12 or
13 that we're gonna be covering for this
video that actually had dropped the
weapon the first time that I actually
fought them so amazing luck for me there
but yeah she's just come right in the
middle honestly you could totally tell
her with a with a vehicle if you wanted
but I just noticed that my fire weapon
custom was gonna do more damage so I
just cut her up with that and it was she
was done in about two seconds afterwards
we're going back to Eden 6 in the anvil
for the mother of Grogan's she's gonna
be dropping the random legendary
artifact she's in a off section usually
we you usually don't go into this
section if you're continuing for the
main quest you'll go up in elevation of
this small grass Hill and then usually
you'll turn right and that's where you
meet tiny Tina brick you know all those
other guys for this quest and the main
story but instead you want to keep going
straight out of this little ledge and
turn right you'll be in some type of
sewer system and then that's where
you're gonna meet the mother of Croghan
she said they didn't spawn for me but
the boss arena looks pretty damn cool so
yeah if you want a farm her she of
course will drop random legendary
artifacts so definitely go give that a
shot
and now we have two more the second last
one being the red jabber in the amber
mind back on eat in six again he's gonna
be dropping any random legendary grenade
mod so any random mod that he happens to
think is a good idea to drop he will
drop that you go to amber mine and you
can go from the spawn point and roughly
at the very top and just hug it right
you'll be at this weird small little
wooden building with a bunch of jabbers
I ran into so many badass vicious wounds
that they just kept exploding sadly the
red jabber wasn't there but he's gonna
be around that location lastly is in
electricity on Promethea this is gonna
be wrist Mick enforcer and I've actually
never heard of this rare spawn before
but I did follow the location it's at
that one section during the section
where you're trying to kill killable in
electricity and you have to go
underneath though these little ramps to
go kill one of the women for the
kilovolt quest to do that of course you
can just hang a right and go down one of
those sections I believe if you take a
right and go all the way to the end that
leaves you to the one quest for the
girls trying to break out her her
girlfriend in prison or something but if
you go to the left this is the area
where her is to make enforcer spawns and
once again he'll be dropping the master
work crossbow legendary sniper rifle
yeah and guys and that's really about it
sorry if this video was a bit long my
apologies I just wanted to detail
everything of course I will leave
everything in the description down below
so if you do want to come back to this
video and you don't want to scrub
through and you don't remember what time
slot it is of course timestamps will be
in the description down below if you
want to know those locations you guys
got some nice legendaries out of that
last week when they were doing this boss
stuff I wasn't really getting many
legendaries or the specific ones that
they were asking for so I don't know if
something was bugged or if I just got
really shitty luck but I heard a lot of
people were getting some bad luck so
maybe it was pretty bugs but who knows
let me know what you guys think about
this in the comments below
I guess we're watching the video like
the V for doing joy subscribe or if
you're new and take care guys have a
great yesterday I'll hopefully be seeing
you next week because next week we might
get some yridian stuff that'll be cool
[Music]
[Music]